real housewife of beverly hills starred
derek kemsley new video has been
released nearly two weeks after the
terrifying robbery
happened the night that she said she's
pays retail for all her clothes oh gosh
you pay retail for everything yes
october 27th 10 53 p.m less than two
hours after that aired dory is home in
bed husband paul out of town their two
young kids asleep when two suspects peer
through a door seemingly plot out their
armed robbery and a minute later shatter
the glass
e.t confirms dorit was held at gunpoint
when she begged for her life one suspect
replied kill her
cops say dorite ended up directing the
men to her valuables one is seen
dragging what we're told is bedding
filled with expensive jewelry and
handbags worth thousands out to a
getaway truck i think this is an
obsession that doesn't hurt anyone
the 45 year old took heat for posting
about her couture collection
interestingly kyle richards was also
robbed in 2017 and andy cohen cautioned
all the housewives about flaunting their
wealth i wouldn't have told the world i
keep millions of dollars worth of
vintage dresses in a detached garage
after a burglar stole all of kyle's
birken bags dory was back filming
housewives just eight days after the
home invasion
police do have a description of the
suspects and their getaway car this is
an open investigation